it's looking like the Democratic Party
does not want to do that but it can
happen and it very well might no matter
what label they use a vote for any
Democrat in 2020 is a vote for the rise
of radical socialism and the destruction
of the American dream
so don't ever forget this election is
about you it's about your family your
future and the fate of your country we
begin our campaign with the best record
the best results the best agenda and the
only positive vision for our country's
future we will protect our Second
Amendment
we will push onward with new medical
frontiers we will come up with the cures
to many many problems to many many
diseases including cancer and others and
we're getting closer all the time we
will eradicate AIDS in America once and
for all and we're very close we will lay
the foundation for landing American
astronauts on the surface of Mars
and above all we will never stop
fighting for the values that hold us
together as one America with your help
with your love and your devotion and
with your drive we are going to keep on
working we are going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under God
and together we will make America
wealthy again we will make America
strong again
we will make America safe again
and we will make America great again
Thank You Orlando thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]